le 20e sommet franco-africain s'ouvre ce
soir au carousel du Louvre à Paris il
réunit 49 nations et tous les regards
seront tourner vers un seul homme
Laurent Désiré Kabila le président de la
République démocratique du Congo dont
l'arrivée au pouvoir a était très
controversée tant elle a provoqué de
massacres aussi bien dans la communauté
outou que touts réist news
bum tapis rouge pour une vingtaine de
chefs d'État africain ce soir à Paris en
préélude au 20e sommet franco-africain
avec une vedette contesté Laurent Désiré
Kabila isolé sur la scène internationale
le président congolais vient chercher un
certificat de bonne conduite en Europe
rencontre avec le Pape Jean-Paul II
audience privée avec le roi Albert II de
Belgique avant le tête- à-tête avec
Jacques Chirac prévu samedi à l'Élysée
autant dire une reconnaissance pour un
homme encore largement infréquentable
accusé de violer les droits de l'homme
Kabila veut faire taire ses détracteurs
vous pouvez voir on a en sommes venus
aujourd'hui à des fabuleuses accusations
de violations des droits de l'omme qui
a-t-on tué qui personne ne peut le
démontrer il y a pas de point et
pourtant Kabila est fortement soupçonné
de CRIM contre l'humanité rappelez-vous
au printemps 97 à l'est du pays celui
qui apparaît comme l'homme des
Américains bousculent les troupes du
maréchal Mobutu dans la foulée plus de
200000 réfugiés utou du Rwanda voisin
sont massacrés ou portés disparu un an
et demi plus tard changement d'alliance
le tombeur de Mobutu lance un appel
public à la chasse au touts plusieurs
dizaines d'entre eux sont lychés à
Kinshasa nous considérons qu'un chef
d'État c'est un symbole d'unité c'est un
symbole d'excellence ce n'est pas le cas
de Monsieur Kabila deux plaintes ont été
déposées contre Kabila en Belgique et
deux autres en France pour crime contre
l'humanité mais l'homme fort du Congo
peut dormir tranquille Kabila ne risque
pas de connaître le pinoch invité
officiellement en France il est protégé
par son statut de chef d'État en
exercice